error truth to all
generations error false Doctrine false
teaching will one day come to an end and
I can't wait how are
you it's nice to see
you I thank God very sincerely for the
honor the sweet privilege of being with
you this weekend for several reasons
perhaps I'll tell you the reasons
tomorrow but now it's 6 minutes after 8
and I want to release you as quickly as
I can so you can get back home it
doesn't take God long to bless his
people and I read somewhere in Ellen
White she says preachers ought to cut
their sermans by half when I heard that
I said why is she talking to me because
she surely was but I'm very grateful to
God I really am I say that sincerely
those of you watching online wherever
you are may the Lord bless you as much
as we know he will bless us in this
building